hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm jerry
another trailer for The Human Centipede
3 final sequence yes regular number 2 I
haven't seen the first two human
centipedes that I saw today that they're
both on Netflix yeah I'm planning on
checking it out this week I don't want
to to be honest I want to see the first
one the second one I we were just
talking for some it was caution yeah
there are things I appreciate about the
second one but it's not a movie I would
tell anybody they have to see of course
if you want to see the second movie
you'll know I want to see this third one
based off the first trailer so let's
check this out good bring back the evil
torture prison as the highest violence
rates to legal to medical costs than any
other institution in the u.s.
correctional system things will have to
change fast I think I have a solution
no more prison fights don't want to send
some guards
Oh no more disrespect we've got to make
a human centipede of our prisons would
usually be on their knees begging for
your mess it's brilliant it's top six
creator of these films times and it's
100% medically accurate I don't speak
with a stupid friend I got him about
this poo fat tears
[Music]
how do you take doc it looks medically
accurate I don't see why someone
couldn't survive a lifetime
peace serve good mood to it
this is violation it's certainly a
violation already you in seeing things
to get the death penalty this is beyond
me de route or to be on castration the
other attraction first human presence
[Music]
this is exactly what America needs
[Music]
action this [ __ ] trilogy dude well I
mean here's the thing is like the first
one is nothing like the like they're all
three really different Phil I mean this
looks different from the first two and
they're all three very different films
you watch the first one as much as this
doesn't need to be a franchise I just
kind of strangely admire the fact that
each time he really makes it a different
thing like it's not like oh we got to
keep this one story going it's like
we're just kind of doing different
things with the same concept which I
sort of appreciate just up amid the
horde of just you know continuous
sequels that all kind of run out of
ideas the style works for this film
because it's really ridiculous and then
they have Tom six and some appear as a
character saying this is all medically
accurate which I do admire them for
doing that that makes it much more fun I
feel like I could probably handle this
one a little bit more than what I hear
about the second one just because of how
over-the-top it is well ya can see the
first one is sort of in the middle like
this the first one starts in familiar
horror movie territory and then does
some at least I think some some
interesting things with it the second
one is really dark and really grungy and
really Neil istic and this one looks
like a over the top sort of grindhouse
movie yeah they've all had a humor but
this one is the most overtly comedic
looking one totally totally it looks
incredibly disturbing anything does look
very disturbing in a very zany kind of
way this time feels like one of those
old-school grindhouse kind of films
where they are not just fun anymore
they're like truly disturbing it's so
that's what it felt like to me like this
looks like legit disturbing I could
admire these movies cuz like going into
the first one that was the most nervous
I'd been to enter a theater in
can't remember how long and watching the
second one last week was like I was
actually nervous to put it on and it was
hard to watch the screen sometime so
these movies do they are kind of scary
to walk into you know this one looks
like it's the most overtly trying to be
I don't know if I could ever describe
any of these as fun but you know
humorous I mean you know Tom six it
seems at least with these movies like
his palette his paints are you know he
paints these pictures in the key of ugly
and you know I think that's it's valid
it's not a place you want to go all the
time or even frequently but you know
some some work ugliness can be
interesting but I'm also one of the very
few people who has found something
interesting about both of the films not
just the first one rating time I will
force myself to go watch The Human
Centipede three anyway guys thanks so
much for saying that was out if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects you could check out
Jerry's playlist reasons to Jerry where
he does Jerry like stuff and you could
follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter where we're trying to get
product placement by getting a lot of
followers I phoned I know I know I
brought this iPhone before but here's
what I surprisingly didn't mention about
the last time I brought the iPhone what
you get great internet access to sites
like pornhub calm redtube calm youporn
calm xvideos calm triple x-- videos calm
[ __ ] calm dooble calm duck well you
know sometimes you just want to see if
the myths are true if sure yeah yeah and
I was hoping to find Tyrone Magnus on
that site oh boy and he was Julian
Catanzaro ooh hi there my name is Julian
Canton's ro and Ryan you need to know
more about Mortal Kombat it really makes
me mad when you think something in the
happens but it doesn't so you start on
the latter cut to the top versus
sub-boss them versus then then you get
that character's ending
I have been playing Mortal Kombat since
I was two yup and now I'm fourteen
thirteen fifteen whoo so just find out
more stuff but you're the best on the
channel thank you Brian
please give me a shout out on a Mortal
Kombat video my youtube is Julian Kenton
Xaro peace well this is an immoral
combat video yeah I know but it is gross
fourteen turn out 15 that is the next
human centipede 14 year old no no that
would be an amazing film I'm talking
about like their freshman in high school
first year and then the principal locks
of school down and he's doing the human
centipede together of all the students
how cool would that be
not cool that would be a great movie I
am a fan of the human centipede movies
but no I don't think so instead of
eating like wacky and stuff you should
make it like super realistic really dark
you know like I want it to be like super
emotional yeah and I want to see like
everything that happens you know like
every detail I want to see it you can go
watch that one I might maybe that'll be
the first one I don't go there might be
the one where I take over for the
franchise so I move over top six right
right get some ideas no Sarge Ilion
Catanzaro whoa
I want to cast real 14 year olds